استمرار هو الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل رغم
تجميد التعديلات القضائيه زعيم كوريا
الشماليه يغلق مدينه باكملها بسبب رصاص
ضائع تقرير صادم نصف طلاب جامعات بريطانيا
يغشون رقميا هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها
لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من اسرائيل حيث لم يمنع قرار رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو تجميد تعديلات
القضائيه مؤقتا لم يمنع استمرار المظاهرات
ضده وضد حكومته اذعلنا قاده الاحتجاج
الاستمرار في تظاهراتهم ضد الخطه المثيره
للجدل المتظاهرون اعتبروا خطبنا نتنياهو
مناوره لتمرير التعديلات فيما وصل الالف
منهم التدفق الى الشوارع في مدن اسرائيليه
عده بما في ذلك تل ابيب مطالبين بالغاء كل
التعديلات التي تتضمنها الخطه وعدم
الاكتفاء بتجميتها مؤقتا
في حديث مروعه جديده تشهدها المدارس
بامريكا هجمت شابه تبلغ من العمر 28 عاما
مدرسه ابتدائيه في مدينه ناشفه ماده لمقتل
الثلاثه الطلاب اطفال وثلاثه موظفين في
المدرسه التابعه لاحدى الكنائس الشرطه
الامريكيه اكدت ان المهاجمه التي قتلت
برصاص عناصر الامن كانت طالبه سابقه
وتنحدر من المدينه نفسها فيما تم كشف عن
رساله تركتها الشابه لاحدى صديقتها قالت
فيها انها تخطط للموت في يوم ارتكاب
الجريمه
بسبب ضياع نحو 600 رصاصه فقط الزعيم
جون امر باغلاق مدينه حصان الحدوديه مع
الصين بالكامل لحين ايجاد هذه الذخيره
المفقوده صحيفه ديلي ميل البريطانيه ذكرت
ان الرصاصات فقدت اثناء انسحاب جنود في
الجيش بعد ان تواجدوا طوال عامين في
المدينه وحين علم كيمبل الامر غضب وامر
بان لا تتم اعاده فتح المدينه قبل ان يتم
ايجاد الرصاص المفقود ومعرفه صاحب الجريمه
ومعاقبته
ارقام صادمه كشفها خبراء بريطانيون حول
نسبه الغش الرقمي العاليه بين الطلاب في
المملكه المتحده الخبراء اكدوا لصحف محليه
ان النصف طلاب جامعات من المحتمل انهم
يستخدمون روبوت الدردشه الذي يعتمد على
الذكاء الاصطناعي
ويستخدمونه لخداع النظام التعليمي في
الامتحانات وكتابه المقالات ما دفع بعض
الجامعات البريطانيه مؤخرا الى تبني اسلوب
اخضاع الطلبه لفحص شفويا لكشف استعانتهم
من عدمه
نختم من عالم الفضاء حيث اشار موقع بزنس
الامريكي الى ظهور ثقبا ضخم على سطح الشمس
يعادل حجمه 20 ضعفا لمحيط الارض الموقع
اوضح ان الثقب الضخم قد يؤدي الى ارسال
رياح شمسيه بسرعه
1.8 مليون ميل في الساعه وباتجاه كوكب
الارض بحلول يوم الجمعه المقبل ويمكن لتلك
الرياح ان تؤدي لتدمير الاقمار الاصطناعيه
وتسبب في ظاهره الشفق الباهر اذا وصلت الى
الارض